[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
non garde le nom postes de surveillants
sahara c'est juste que c'est moi qu'ils
présenteraient maintenant ça y est me
alors là vous et moi en place et je suis
de retour n'ont pas atteint tu as vite
retrouver ta voix en tout cas pour
quelqu'un qui avait alors une angine
arrête de me la faire à l'envers j'ai
tout regardé des huit points tb j'ai
regardé en replay
je regarde mon grip l'aide parce que
c'est fou c'est super ça donnerait
bénéficier parce que tu rates à la télé
tu pour revoir la télé se consomme
finalement différemment mais non c'est
pas bien de dorothée aux arêtes de
noailles un poisson nommé wanda
j'ai tout vu est-ce qu'il ya du nouveau
déjà oui il ya du nouveau quai mais
qu'en est il regarde j'ai mis ma voiture
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait sous ma voiture
un mec un voisin qui m'en veut ils
n'arrêtent pas de vomir sur ma voiture
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est très
dommage ou vomir sur ma voiture déjà
fait mais ce qui sait pas c'est que j'ai
mis une caméra à parce que nous n'avions
pas con et je vais le trouver
oh [ __ ] le mec se fait plus respectés
par personne quoi les gens lui vomissent
sur sa caisse mais c'est quand même
mais la question que je me pose quand
même là dessus c'est qui est assez
inconscient pour aller vomir sur la
bagnole d'hanouna ce que je peux te dire
que le mec quand il va le retrouver va
pas le démolir
il va pas lui casser la gueule il va le
cacher on de lui casser
c'est bon pour moi ça c'est très bon
c'est très bon pour que tu veux que je
te dise rien non mais j'aime gêné à alex
ça va bien se passer
je suis bon et nos journées et la suisse
était latente est pas en train de te
faire épiler le cif les piscines étaient
si je sais pas monsieur apparemment ce
féministe ça pourra peut-être que servir
m'a manqué ses grands 8 était pâtissier
roselyne bachelot laurence ferrari était
invitée principale elle a rencontré le
cuistot et a montré son rouleau et en ça
va selon lourdeur excuse moi les filles
du grand huit actions super elle
m'invite à parler dans le grand huit
évidemment que j'y vais pas parler de
quoi elle parlait de plaintes plus que
je fais pas juste ton épisode raconte
tous les jours chez d'autres activités
je fais un peu de radio
voilà et puis pour parler également d'un
prime qui arrive ce soir pardon hein
cqfd à 21 heures ce soir sur d8
retrouver dans une ambiance champêtre et
chamarrée les meilleurs artistes médias
qui s'enchaînent dans des parodies plus
hilarantes les unes que les autres
brian bensetti mais encore plein
d'autres seront là qu'est vadam c'est
jamel debbouze vraiment un beau
programme
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais pas ton caisse que
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore je le cherche
je cherche quoi je cherche la chute de
l'épisode ton travail je suis bien j'ai
pas la juger par les gars y avait de bon
au bout d'un moment tu as tout fait a
montré qu'au cul qu'on a fait aux
douches einstein chandelier j'ai fait
sur deux y est t'as fait sciemment donné
gerber depuis hier moi je vois plus
qu'un truc quoi bein chaque iep est à
boudry a tout fait y en a juste passé de
chacun
il va pas nous traiter d'escroc l'assuré
pilote de série on aspire fait pire déjà
[Musique]
là c'est adorable mais merci non mais je
pense la même chose en plus donc c'est
pour ça que c'est qu'être ouais ouais
bah merci à rats mais moi aussi partout
ouais bisous dans star a pris quand ils
trouvaient que j'étais assez brillant
sur le début d'émission de vendredi qui
est que j'ai présentée et je suis assez
d'accord avec lui patois gamme et des
nuits torrides et où ce qu'on camille
non pas vraiment personne n'a vu camilla
non parce que ça commençait à
m'inquiéter là l'émission a démarré
qu'une bonne vingtaine de minutes j'ai
pas de scénario j'ai rien et je suis
tout seul avec ma mère finalement hockey
et camille qu'il est ou ce qu'on ampute
un [ __ ] tu l'as fait deux heures
camille tu peux pas seulement la ville
vient de commencer le tournage d'un
ruisseau crâne j'ai besoin que moi pas
je peux pas du tout aujourd'hui encore
d'inventer makoni mec il est 19h10 alors
à 19h17 encore ton est en train de
tourner de ta merde tu crois que tu es
bien si ça repart
bon les auteurs sont partis aussi bine
en moi un immense service
appuyez sur entrée tout de suite